the dopamine system is really important
to understand so we've talked about
norepinephrine kind of gets you going
acetylcholine is the spotlight of
attention
but dopamine's main role
is to be released anytime you achieve a
milestone or you think you're on the
right path it's unreasonable for us to
think oh i've got an hour i'm going to
plop down and write beautifully for an
hour my best work we need to accept that
there's a period of agitation and stress
that accompanies the dropping into these
highly concentrated states now in terms
of the reward that accompanies um the
feeling that we're funneling into that
that groove of being productive in in
one regime like for you writing this
book
the dopamine system is tethered to those
states of focus
and it's what mother nature designed so
that neural plasticity would occur and
you would want to continue those
behaviors again
in the future but unfortunately there's
a kind of obsession with the idea that
it's all supposed to feel good and it
does feel good but there's a whole
staircase in which it feels kind of
lousy